okay movie review in time and we're
doing another Cronenberg movie yeah
early Cronenberg yeah this is actually
his first feature film he had made a
couple of independent films before this
I think crimes of the future in stereo
which I don't I think those were short
films but this was like his first major
release and this is shivers yes it was
actually released in the United States
initially as they came from within yeah
about per virus well the interesting
thing about this movie oh my god there's
like someone I do sex zombies yeah maybe
an attack zombies but because it's
Cronenberg you know there has to be like
a lot of squicky like parasitic chef
weird body organ replacement things were
parasites try to get in and replace
organs they talked about that for a
while
it's weird I'll tell you one thing
though this movie is aesthetic as [ __ ]
it's taking place like in this apartment
complex and it's just it looks so
1977-78 the decor and I'm you know Dan
Bell would love this this belongs in one
of those dead mall series looks really
cool yeah this was actually filmed I
think it's a you know he's filled an
actual building obviously cuz it's film
bro thoroughly cheap it actually came
out in 1975 and they filmed it on nuns
Island which is near Montreal and the
whole I love the beginning of this movie
and I'm gonna get into this a little bit
too but I loved the beginning of this
movie because the beginning of it is
pretty much like a super 70s commercial
yeah for this upscale apartment building
called Starliner towers and they're
talking about it like it's a cruise ship
like a cruise ship and it's special and
all is it is a spaceship I guess yeah it
all it is is an apartment complex with a
swimming pool in a store in it basically
it has like they make a big deal out of
like there's like an on-site medical
clinic and you never have to leave you
never have to leave the island and all
this yes and you look at it it's just a
square yeah swear box like looked really
kick-ass for back then but yeah yeah yes
all the apartments are super super
senses oh yeah cuz I guess it was early
70s getting laid
60s and seeing it you know I'm old
enough to remember when buildings looked
like that yeah and I forgot how cheap
that [ __ ] look man a certain weather the
construction materials looked pretty
cheap the furniture looked cheap they're
presented as if it's really high-tech
like something out of Clockwork Orange
and you're I'm looking at the
countertops and the furniture that
they're using I'm going yeah that shit's
all plywood that's all warped and
cracked by now well yeah yeah they
didn't really care if it was any good
they just wanted it to look good yeah
they didn't really care how long it
would last and that's did a lot of that
stuff didn't even last through the 80s I
wonder if that building is still there
I'm sure someone will be able I'm sure
it's there everybody's thinking it might
be there they probably just renovated
the inside of it usually the interiors
were they just weren't built to last
yeah yeah but one of the things I love
about this movie like I said it was his
first feature film now there was kind of
a funny story behind this I think we
mentioned it on a couple of other our
other shows about Cronenberg movies cuz
we did the brood and we did Videodrome
you know Canada at the time I'm not sure
about now but they had this whole kind
of tax break thing where you like get
tax money from the government to make
movies and things of that nature so he
was actually applying for that for that
grid like to get this movie made yeah he
were a company that needed a tax
write-off he just found a guy who was
making a movie and you gave him a bunch
of money and then you wrote off like he
gave him more than that yeah it was kind
of like a good tax shelter so guys like
Cronenberg were able to make a decent
living during that time and make some
pretty cool flicks that never would have
been made anywhere else
yeah these movies are weird well what
ended up happening with this one was
that it took so long for them to get
back to him about the funding that he
was actually considering going to
Hollywood because Roger Corman had
expressed an interest in making this
film could David Cronenberg also wrote
the screenplay which will be quite
obvious if ya watch the movie is it's
Cronenberg II in his [ __ ] yeah but
finally the government came through and
you know gave him the money and he made
the movie and after the movie was made
and people in Canada saw it everybody
flipped the [ __ ] out because they're
like taxpayers are paying yes sorted
horrible like exploitation yeah kind of
was imagine zombies zombies chasing you
want to have sex with you
yes some of them are gay it's kind of
yeah it's just very funny because I mean
it's probably it's fairly mild now I
think other days it was but in 1975 this
was probably like a big deal so you can
see how people were like morally
outraged you know they guess but David
Cronenberg is actually he was kind of
laughing about it I watched an interview
with the more he's talking about this
movie and he said well you know after
the movie came out it was actually the
first of these you know
government-funded movies it actually
turned a profit
yeah then they kind of stopped why I
think um yeah but you know at the time
like in the media that was this big
thing it's like oh my god it's this big
orgy of sex and violence and everything
like I said the the movie is generally
known nowadays as shivers it was
initially released in the US as they
came from within
also known as the parasite murders or
his original title for it which I love
or Jing of the blood parents idea which
yeah that's pretty awesome so another
interesting thing about this too is that
you can really see the influence of this
movie on a lot of later movies yeah now
when Cronenberg was at this is like
several years later like late 70s early
80s he was at some Film Festival or
something and some other director or a
movie maker or something accused him of
ripping off alien with this movie even
though this movie came out more than
four years before alien right because
you know it had a similar kind of thing
where there was like parasites inside
the like bust out and stuff yeah also
the the movie slither paid obvious
homage to the very iconic scene in this
movie where Barbara Steele is and naked
in the bathtub and like one of the
parasites crawls up the plughole of the
bathtub the whole premise of this movie
is that here is this state-of-the-art
wonderful hi-tech apartment building
that's on this island that it has
everything you'd ever need it has tennis
courts it has pools and as I'm here
doctor it has stores that had malls and
all this other kind of stuff you never
have to leave so somehow they they kind
of explained like where the parasite
comes from but the parasite was
initially or so they say engineered to
replace people's organs right it was
like these two doctors that were working
on it and they said we wanted it to be
able to go into your body and like you
know replace your kidney if it was
messed up or something which you know
that seems like a reasonable idea
but then you find out later on that one
of the doctors with like a mad
scientist-type doctor yeah and he
thought that humans had become too
intellectual or too removed from their
primal urges right yeah so he actually
sort of made the parasite kind of get
into your body and then it basically
just made you want to [ __ ] everything
inside yeah mate yeah it's like an
aphrodisiac like an aphrodisiac sexually
and like an aphrodisiac slash STD yeah
yeah
and it involves schoolgirls and just all
kinds of stuff what one of the things
that struck me about the movie is that
there's a lot of dialogue between these
doctors yeah and it's and the guys come
off as being like very corporate and
very believable that's the way a lot of
guys were when I was a little kid the
way I remember that and it's kind of
funny to hear hear that hear their
conversations because you're like I
remember when guys were like that my
uncle was kind of like that you know me
you think it'll yeah you know culture
has changed a lot so it's kind of like
looking backwards into the end time
about the way businessmen thought what
are you interested because there was no
internet they you had to think things up
yeah yeah no I mean you had to talk to
talk face to face it's just weird when
you see it you alone I'm talking about
well it kind of the cool thing about
this movie like I said it's you know
it's his first feature film so it's not
at quite as accomplished to some of his
later stuff but you can really see the
potential that he was gonna have you
know because he made this when he was
quite young and you could see a lot of
his ideas that were already pretty fully
formed I mean the whole idea of this
building and it's sort of isolated
because it's on an island and it's
almost serving as like a petri dish type
thing yeah and I love the way he did
like the juxtaposition between
particularly the opening scenes where
you see this you know cute young couple
come in and they're gonna rent an
apartment in the Starliner towers and
there's like the the guy who's like the
rental agent or whatever and he's all
like smarmy and like telling them all
about this w like oh it's so awesome and
stuff and then the movie cuts between
that and the old doctor yeah killing yes
school girl Annabelle yeah it was almost
kind of like it looked like he's trying
to rape her - it's hard to tell what was
going on
and you find out later on there was
actually like the typhoid mary he was
she was the one that had it she was the
one that had the parasite he wrote a
dinner like you know she was like the
guinea pig and it turned out that she
was kind of promiscuous and had like was
having an affair with the bunch yeah
once she got infected she was having sex
with everybody well no she had been
beforehand Oh was she okay because that
was yeah I guess so that was kind of way
it was worded right yeah that was kind
of one of the themes of the movie was
that even before the parasite started
taking everyone over and making everyone
[ __ ] everyone and raping this was 70s
back when you had to worry about
promiscuous fifteen-year-old school
girls attacking you everybody yeah we
had to guard themselves from these plaid
miniskirt wearing school girls all the
time and trying to attack grown men you
know yeah I know I can't count the
number yeah my four brothers had to
watch out Rubin gangs of school yeah
Catholic school girls but yeah I mean it
was like one of the points in the movie
I think that he was trying to make was
that there was a whole bunch of sordid
[ __ ] going on before the parasites even
got there like everyone was having it
affairs everyone isn't that so it's
almost kind of 1970s yeah well it was
almost kind of like I would almost
almost call this a black comedy yeah
because you can tell that he's saying
look here was all this stuff that was
going on before the parasites even got
there yeah parasites just brought it to
the surface so it's almost like he was
copped he was commenting on like the
hypocritical yeah was nature of these
like upright people 70s was wild anyway
and they're trying to in a way they're
kind of promoting the Starliner the
Starliner towers the towers is kinda
like being a veiled love hotel in a way
yeah I mean that's true it had so it
looked kind of like a one of those Love
Boat 70s love resorts it did kind of
look yeah tacky
it's sleazy con uh you know 70s porn
kind of way look like that everything
looked like everything looked like that
yeah but like me Z times Z Z times it
really was yeah well the whole decade
was
yeah a sticky film disgusting yeah it
was kind of fun too but I mean I was
pretty a sixties free love culture just
it got too excessive around and too long
yeah well like I said I really like this
is one of the kind of things where it's
kind of an ensemble piece so it's not
like you know some of the acting is good
some of it's a little it you know it's
there's not like a lot of
characterization yeah I think the best
guy in it is the guy that plays Rollo
who is the doctors the other doctor the
doctor's buddy or whatever the one
that's like just constantly eating
pickles yeah which that's like a phallic
thing I think because he even like at
one point even makes a big deal of like
hey you gonna eat that pickle and the
guy like throws the half-eaten bagel and
[ __ ] like that
so it because the parasites look like
slugs or worms now initially David
Cronenberg said that he wanted them to
look like spiders right but because they
didn't have the budget he's like
obviously it's much easier to make a
parasite that looks like a slug then
make one that looks like a spider
crawling out of people's mouths and [ __ ]
like that so that's why they ended up
looking like that but in a way I think
that worked better because they look
like dicks
yeah and spiders don't look like dick
it's a weird it's a weird flick that
kind of texture the texture of this
movie is kind of strange if I want to
call it a texture I guess it is it kind
of reminds me in some ways like extra
extra it is very it has a similar tone
yeah kind of like extra mixed with the
brood kind of mixed yeah like I said
it's it's like a weird juxtaposition of
like this clinical like unfeeling oh
yeah everyone is kind of like it's got a
corporate medical kind of a vibe right
which a lot of his movies did
particularly ones that he wrote but then
on the but then on the other hand you
have that juxtaposed against this really
disgusting like visceral like these
[ __ ] slugs like coming mouths and
busting out of their stomachs and
crawling their vaginas yeah and the
special effects are not good but they're
good enough
wait 75 ways shot you knew what they
were doing I mean if you if you kind of
look at it from the 1975 point of view I
mean I the slugs look pretty good yeah
it looks pretty gross like them coming
out of people's mouths like like gross
ass tongues and [ __ ] movie was made for
enough
it really was yeah it really didn't cost
Hurley it kind of has a homemade feel to
it but you know in a good way the energy
kind of adds to the creepiness of the
movie yeah almost kind of like Martin
level for David like like Martin
although the transfer that's on to be
TVs a lot better than the transfers of
Martin it's a better preserve yeah
actually don't know shivers the DVD
might be out of print look I think you
can get a blu-ray in the UK I don't know
if you can get one here because I heard
people I watched a couple other people's
reviews of it and people were
complaining I don't know how old those
reviews were but people were complaining
that the DVD was at a print looked good
on to be yeah and that and that some
people that were selling them like on
eBay or something wanted like hundreds
of dollars but very rare you know it's
just kind of like another interesting
thing I wanted to say about this movie
too and I think the reason why it caused
such a big controversy when it came out
was because and this is going back to
what I was saying - about this being
like a little bit of a black comedy is
that I mean it's a subtle black comedy
yes it's kind of like more a satire than
a black comedy I guess it had some funny
parts in it yeah it did one of my
favorite parts as funny parts was then
when that laundry woman gets the
parasite that big fat laundry woman yeah
and then she peeks out of her apartment
door and she's like all made up like
Tammy Faye Bakker yeah I'm hungry yeah I
like the two skinny gay guys walking
down the the hallway and they're
following that following a guy the guy
runs through his apartment to hide and
they're knocking on the door hey yeah
hey I want to go to a party there are
some kind of like even for today they're
kind of like I mean there's shots of
like little girls like kissing grown men
on the mouth yeah so it's still a little
it's pretty risky yeah it's still a
little controversial yeah for today but
you know one of the things - I want to
say about it is that I think the reason
that it caused such a stink when it came
out to a large extent was because you
know horror movies most of the time you
know the
guy gets defeated or it's like things
resume to the status quo or whatever but
David Cronenberg in this movie does not
seem to be condemning the parasite thing
he's he's almost making it seem like
it's kind of a good thing like maybe
this is sort of a good thing I don't
know I'm not gonna read into it but you
could read it either way because the
pairs are not destroyed and then I think
he thinks it's funny it yes yeah that's
what I mean I think he's making a
statement about like these hypocritical
people there you is the message is
you're all [ __ ] yeah but then the
parasite just makes them feel like [ __ ]
it whatever yeah we're just gonna be
like that and then at the end when
they're like you know leaving the island
as though they're gonna like infect the
world with the parasites and everything
like that it's almost seen as like women
like a liberation and I think that
that's why a lot of people flipped out
of it because they're like well it
almost makes it look like he thinks that
it would be good I couldn't I couldn't
make the movie today they put it they
put a modern spin on it and condemn you
to this guy to be locked up in prison
probably but it wasn't meant to be taken
seriously it was just a yeah it was just
a take on it was just a take on a zombie
movie and yeah and honestly like I said
I just I watched a lot of interviews
with David Cronenberg over the years
talking about his various movies and he
actually has he has a very intellectual
and clinical approach to making movies
but he also has a really really nasty
sense of humor and I think that you know
a really like dark sense of humor and I
think a lot of that comes through in his
movies and I don't know like if if
you're not a big fan of his work or you
haven't seen a lot of his movies I think
that it's easy to miss yeah because it's
very subtle but I think it happened I
mean it happened in the brood he's
always like making fun he's like poking
holes in sort of institutions and you
know he's kind of trying to bring it
down from within I guess yeah you know
what I mean and I think I liked that's
what I kind of liked about this movie is
that you know the fact that the
Starliner towers it was like this you
know like a petri dish and that was
where this whole thing was gonna come
bubbling to the surface and it was just
gonna go out and infect everybody yeah
and it wasn't gonna be bad it was just
pandemic of [ __ ] she's trying to make
she's trying to make a sound high-minded
and artistic in artsy fartsy it's just a
[ __ ] pandemic that's all yeah but nobody
is actually saying y'all [ __ ] anyway
yes oh yeah yeah like I said he was he's
condemning the hub yeah it's just funny
if pretending that you're not right and
you know acting like you're kind of a
big deal or you're all kind of like yeah
we're gonna live on this island it's
gonna be all a service but yeah
underneath layer of propriety yeah
that's a good that's a good way of
putting it yeah oh yeah like I said so
at the time it's it's gotten a lot
better ratings over the years I think at
the time most of the reviews were
negative but aged well because you
called it repulsive and what it aged
well because now you're seeing an old
movie that's that's trying to pull this
off and it's more hilarious in a way yes
yeah yeah I don't think Cronenberg was
just a weird guy and he just tried to
take whatever strange ankle he could
find and mash it in together so you know
a pandemic of [ __ ] zombies was just kind
of something that had never been done
these please always repel people will
cut into people and will mash slugs and
people killing each other and you know
and and hey wanna party you know what a
go to a party never be funny you know so
it's Cronenberg because he's one of the
very very few directors maybe the only
one that can kind of pull off the
tightrope act between exploitative
sleaze yeah and like kind of an
intellectual artistic statement it's
really hard to get away with that [ __ ]
and as far as I can think I mean if
anybody else knows I there's probably a
couple other ones but he's kind of the
main one that can get away with that
just some of the infected people men are
just hilarious yeah when you look in the
background you see what they're doing
they're gonna jump into swimming pools
and stuff and they're coming to get ya
just funny you know great premise and
it's just funny the way it was kind of
picked up on later because you know how
much Cronenberg loves that bodily
transformations yes skinny old skinny
old hairy dudes in their underwear
trying to run you run you down you know
just chasing you down hallways you know
and there's all these a like dick
parasites yeah
like scooching down the hall even with
blood trails this freakish combination
of like big old fat women and little
kids and just just everything all humans
all humans could be in fat and infested
so they they just all start acting crazy
and they attack each other too so it's
not just you know uninfected people you
know they seem to be preferring
unaffected people well because the
parasite was trying to pass it on yeah
that's what the parasite did it got in
it changed your behavior but they were
all made it so you would pass it to
people that didn't have they were all
molesting each other too as they were
attacking yes I don't remember very much
nudity really in it there's not a lot
that I don't it's there's a lot of
suggestion of certainly going it's not
x-rated though no but I mean there is
kind of a famous scene with with Lynn
Lowry who plays the nurse yeah where you
know her boyfriend the doctor is like
talking on the phone and she's like
taking all her clothes off yeah yeah and
actually the the schoolgirl you do kind
of see her naked from this yeah but
she's not that young that shows yes
she's supposed to be 15 but I think that
she's probably about 20 as much yeah
yeah so it's so it's not but they're
yeah it's not like a super
there's boobies and stuff but that's
yeah you watch them free on to be TV
free boobies yeah go check out
everybody's like big dealers yeah it's
just kind of a cool snapshot of the past
you know of what they were thinking
about what they were doing in the
seventies and where Cronenberg was
coming from you know yeah if you like if
you like Cronenberg movies you know like
the brood this is it's a little rougher
probably yeah in the brood cuz this is
you can tell us you can tell it's an
early yeah it's like his first feature
film so you can tell there's a little
bit of it does kind of have that creepy
alienated feeling of like your being in
a secluded area where there isn't a
whole lot of people even though there's
people in the damn shot for some reason
it feels like there's not people there I
don't know why the way he shoots things
that I'm doing I was isolated
although they're showing you ten people
right there and Fran but for some reason
it feels like it's isolated from the
rest of the world you know it's right
I'm not a filmmaker but out of it is the
decor that decor is very kind of Spartan
looking in retro and aesthetic you know
it's a very archaic kind of decor but it
still kind of looks good in a weird way
you'll see them walk maybe that's why to
us it seems because even though we grew
up with houses looking like that yeah
nowadays when you see a house like this
you know it's like you said it's on an
abandoned yeah it's like real a channel
or like yeah you don't know there's
nothing like that you could only walk
into a room like that now it is if you
walked into a ruin yes I'm not I don't
know if it does that for younger people
but we're all enough to remember things
looking like that know what they look
like today
yeah the only place you'd find that now
would be in some abandoned place that
had been walled up for decades right
it's kind of a creepy feeling yeah
walking into a tube and I want to say to
that it's like I'm not a filmmaker so
I'm not sure exactly what methods he
uses but David Cronenberg is very good I
think he uses like a lot of wide shots
and a lot of shots from like slightly
below eye level yeah so it kind of gives
you this weird sense like you're real
small of yeah you being smaller than the
surrounding area so that might
contribute to yeah because a lot of his
work has that like you said a very
isolating very almost intimidating cold
sort of look to it and I think a lot of
it has to do with his camera work the
camera work in this one is not super
fancy but it really does give you that
feeling I wanted to mention to when you
were talking about the decor those green
round lamps oh yeah they were pretty
cool in that in the bedroom with the guy
with the with the parasite in the
stomach that was talking to his stomach
they wouldn't have survived it today
those were paper they were right yeah
cuz I had some like that but they were
red but yeah they were they were so so
pretty with like all the green [ __ ] like
copies or something kind of like that
today it would be cool if you could get
ones that were like wrought iron it
reminded me of a lamp that my
grandmother used to have in her house
back in the 70s that was like
cylindrical but it had like these this
lists hammered silver like collars there
was like two or three
and then from each of the colors was
hanging all these little green like
jewels yeah she had earlier but they
were all green yeah yeah there was like
a yellow light in there so it was like
this really pretty like green and I like
that old plastic stuff that they had all
time what was it called it was used in
lamps and furniture back in the 60s and
the 70s and it was kind of like a
colored plastic and then had sometimes
like gold highlights in it crystals yeah
I forgot what it was called though yeah
I can't remember too we looked it up one
day and then I was like oh yeah that's
right now I can remember again not lycra
but you don't see that anymore and if
you find it it's expensive yeah they
want a lot for that well yeah because
there's not much of us not much I guess
because it was cheap back in the day
right yeah so if you like Cronenberg and
you want to see kind of where he came
from this was his first feature film
other teeth the only things he'd made
before this work you know students don't
shortcut I was called the lucite there
you go Lucy yeah yeah that was that was
some weird [ __ ] and I saw a piece of
loose sight like lamp there was a new
production they want a lot for that yeah
I guess because there's no facilities to
make it anymore yeah probably not it
looked like amber like in any color you
wanted yeah it was all kind of yeah it's
gone now
yeah if there was like tons I used to go
in people's houses all the time and say
that [ __ ] yeah but yeah that kind of
reminded me of it I feel like the decor
and this is not quite as crazy as
remember in the brood like with that one
house it was like the grandparents house
or something like that and the wallpaper
and that was like oh my god yeah that's
like the 70s wallpaper I've ever seen
yeah you only only remember from our
childhood yeah the funniest thing about
this one I mean other than those
beautiful lamps which I actually love I
don't think they were tacky at all but
the thing I remember too this the the
guy with the parasites in his stomach he
came home and sat on his sofa and we had
like one of those really low down like
white leather sofas but like really
really close to the ground yeah and then
his [ __ ] shag carpet with yeah the
little legs like three and a half inches
long I mean I don't even think he could
vacuum that get caught up in the
powerhead little rotating brush the only
good thing though all the drinking and
coke you were doing in the 70s if you
fell onto the shag then it would be
sawed off bodily fluid
just soaked into that [ __ ] over-testing
I don't think they I don't think people
kept that kind of carpeting for long cuz
you don't think you can clean it
properly
I don't like carpet at all remember
Barbarella they had that carpet on the
damn walls and the ceilings of the
spaceships I know yeah look like fur
talk about a dust trap which yeah it
looks neat but it's just really not
dirty it's like you've never cleaned it
a good for a few weeks and then it would
get all muddy and stinky and especially
if like while the people smoke in and
show like them yeah yeah those wet spots
[Laughter]
like a fish tank in here alright so go
check out
shivers or they came from with it or
whatever it's on to be TV right now if
you want to go watch it for free
because if you want the DVD you're gonna
have to pay out the ass for it cuz
apparently them yeah so yeah go check
it's a rare movie go check it out if you
were into Cronenberg and remember if you
like our show to like share subscribe
and share with all your friends on all
your social media also if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to make a one-time donation also
this show is going up on Friday so
actually tomorrow which is Saturday July
28th 2018 our friends a starry night the
goth dark wave slash post-punk band from
Miami are playing in Orlando Florida at
Will's pub and me and Tom will be there
I will have a table with a couple of
books for sale and some other a couple
other things and stuff so if you're in
the Central Florida area and you want to
come out and see a really kick-ass band
and meet me and Tom because we're gonna
be there to come down to Wills pub in
Orlando that's Saturday July 28th its
2018 come down
say hi to us and remember to check out
our regular episodes which are up every
Tuesday and our movie reviews which are
up every Friday and that will do it for
this installment we will see you next
time
bye